seehofer in schwieriger mission weiter
keine einheit in der europäischen union
der neue verteilungs plan für aus seenot
gerettet flüchtlinge findet wenig
zustimmung
offene fragen nach dem lkw crash in
limburg was trieb diesen man dazu einen
geklauten laster in mehrere autos zu
steuern und puma der pannen panzer zdf
recherchen zeigen deutschlands vorzeige
panzer ist nur bedingt einsatzbereit
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg gegen abend und ein
herzliches willkommen in allen norbert
lehmann ist auch dabei für den sport
eine schöne dandorfer mir mit kleinen
schritten zu einer großen lösung in der
flüchtlingspolitik das war die hoffnung
von innenminister seehofer beim treffen
seiner eu-kollegen in luxemburg wollte
er verbündete für das finden was er mit
frankreich italien und malta auf den weg
gebracht hat einen plan
erst mal nur für gerettete
bootsflüchtlinge vor italien und malta
ein viertel davon derzeit wenige hundert
im jahr würde deutschland aufnehmen wenn
auch andere länder mitmachen nur
übergangsweise und teilnehmer könnten
jederzeit aussteigen wenn die zahlen
wieder hochgehen
trotzdem gab es erst kritik im eigenen
land und jetzt große zurückhaltung bei
den eben kollegin anne gellinek es
sollte ein silberstreif am horizont
werden deutschland und frankreich als
vorbilder in der europäischen
flüchtlingspolitik migranten die aus
seenot gerettet werden und den malta
oder italien an landen werden nach
festen quoten auf dazu freiwillig bereit
eu mitgliedsstaaten verteilt so der plan
in luxemburg wird der deutsche
innenminister bei seinen eu-kollegen um
zu sagen und bekommt viele abfuhren nur
sieben länder sind bereit bei einer
geregelten verteilung von
bootsflüchtlingen mitzumachen
neben deutschland frankreich italien und
malta sind dass luxemburg irland und
portugal
der rest muss noch überzeugt werden in
der zeit wird sich herausbilden wir
immer dabei ist und wer gelegentlich
dabei ist so die länder gab es in der
vergangenheit auch und wer im laufe des
prozesses sich anschließen kann
das deutsch französische pilot projekt
findet also bislang wenig anhänger
mittelmeeranrainer wie griechenland und
spanien winken ab weil sie selbst mehr
flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben als
italien
andere fürchten dass eine vereinbarte
quote noch mehr migranten in see stechen
lässt osteuropäer und österreicher
sträuben sich weiterhin prinzipiell
gegen eine verteilung
aber was natürlich selbstverständlich
ist für uns hier in europa ist dass wir
menschen leben retten
dagegen spricht sich keiner aus ganz im
gegenteil menschenleben retten heißt
aber noch nicht dass wir einmal
verteilen mechanismus hiermit
implementierung von dicken brettern die
noch zu bohren sein spricht seehofer
nach dem treffen
seinem ziel einer automatischen
verteilung von bootsflüchtlingen ist der
in luxemburg kaum näher gekommen
flüchtlingen zu helfen bedeutet auch
fluchtursachen zu bekämpfen menschen
eine perspektive in ihrer heimat zu
bieten mit dem nothilfe treuhandfonds
der eu werden unter anderem projekte in
westafrika gefordert so gefördert so
auch in guinea wo der großteil der
menschen in armut lebt tim krüger
berichtet 100
es gibt kaum eine familie die nicht von
migration betroffen ist erzählen die
menschen in meinem ort in guinea
nachrichten von gekenterten booten und
ertrunkenen bedeuten hier oftmals leid
und verzweiflung
boubacar diallos ältester sohn ist im
vergangenen jahr auf dem mittelmeer ums
leben gekommen
was nun auch mein zweiter sohn unterwegs
ist bringt mich um ihn ist mein größtes
problem
ich will ihn nicht verlieren so wie
meinen ersten der lokale fußballklub vor
manu verliert immer wieder spieler weil
sich zuviele richtung norden absetzen
erzählt uns der trainer
das hat der mangel an jobs so einen
guten häusern die armut deswegen suchen
die jungen menschen in europa ein
besseres leben
ich bin sofort bereit über das meer nach
spanien oder italien zu gehen mir fehlt
nur noch das geld
[Musik]
mit rund 100 millionen euro aus dem
afrika treuhandfonds versucht die eu
diese sogenannten fluchtursachen in
guinea zu bekämpfen durch
ausbildungskurse in landwirtschaft oder
technik etwa rückkehrer mamadou bah sie
hat bereits eine gescheiterte odysee
hinter sich und will nun irgendwie
wieder fuß fassen
ich hoffe dass dieses projekt wir helfen
wird wieder auf die beine zu kommen ich
bete zu gott aber wenn das nicht
funktioniert dann wird es hier sehr
schwierig für mich
seiner familie habe niemand geholfen
sagt boubacar diallo auch die regierung
nicht nun bietet er seinen zweitältesten
sohn nichts passiert in sachen dragset
wird der ton immer rauer
die regierung in london verbreitete
heute bundeskanzlerin merkel habe sich
in einem telefonat mit premier johnson
in der nordirland frage kompromisslos
gezeigt downing street sieht die
gespräche zum scheitern verurteilt
sollte dies auch eben linie sein
eu-ratspräsident tusk mahnte johnson
daraufhin auf twitter es gehe nicht
darum ein dummes schwarzer peter spiel
zu gewinnen
nach deutschland warum hat ein mann mit
einem gestohlenen lkw im hessischen
limburg mehrere autos gerammt
der vorfall von gestern nachmittag mit
mehreren verletzten gibt nach wie vor
rätsel auf das motiv des festgenommenen
syrers ist unklar
die behörden ermitteln in alle
richtungen stefan schlosser hat die
details war es ein anschlag eine
amokfahrt oder war der tatverdächtige
unzurechnungsfähig zu den hintergründen
und zum motiv des mutmaßlichen täters
kann der bundesinnenminister auch am tag
nach dem vorfall
angaben machen ich kann ihnen zur stunde
noch nicht sagen wie diese tat zu
qualifizieren ist gestern abend soll der
festgenommene einen lkw fahrer gewaltsam
aus seinem fahrzeug gezerrt haben er
übernimmt das steuer und fährt
ungebremst in mehrere autos die vor
einer ampel warten neun personen werden
verletzt darunter der tatverdächtige der
32 jahre alte syrer sitzt zurzeit in
untersuchungshaft und schweigt offenbar
bislang zu den vorwürfen
die staatsanwaltschaft frankfurt wirft
ihm versuchten mord vor
seit 2005 10 lebt er in deutschland und
ist hier der polizei wegen rauschgift
und gewaltdelikten aufgefallen
noch in der nacht durch sucht die
polizei zwei wohnungen und sicher
beweismaterial das derzeit ausgewertet
wird
ein terroristischer anschlag wird bis
zur stunde von den ermittlungsbehörden
weder ausgeschlossen noch bestätigt es
werde weiter in alle richtungen
ermittelt petra wagner ist am unfallort
in limburg gibt es mittlerweile hinweise
auf ein mutiger danach suchen die
ermittler noch heute sind ja die
wohnungen wir haben es gehört durchsucht
worden
dabei sind datenträger sind die
mobiltelefone sichergestellt worden
und die werden jetzt gerade mit
hochdruck ausgewertet aus
sicherheitskreisen haben wir heute
erfahren dass die staatsschutz behörden
von bund und ländern heute früh bei
einer telefonkonferenz das geschehen
hier in limburg als einen terrorakt
bezeichnet haben und beschrieben haben
aber natürlich gehen die ermittler zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt von auch anderen
möglichen motiven ausschließen keines
aus zumal sich der 32 jährige syrer
bisher wohl nicht zur tat geäußert hatte
informationen aus limburg von peter
wagner vielen dank in den usa hat sich
präsident auch von parteifreunden viel
kritik eingehandelt mit seiner
entscheidung us-soldaten aus nord syrien
abzuziehen
er lasse die kurden im stich die
wichtige verbündete waren im kampf gegen
den as rom verwahrte sich heute gegen
vorwürfe
man lasse niemanden fallen sondern werde
den kurdischen kämpfern auch
weiterhelfen
ines trams berichtet erster militär
basen der usa in nordsyrien verlassen
die soldaten abgezogen der ball
demonstrieren kurdische veteranen gegen
den abzug
lange haben sie an der seite der usa
gegen den sogenannten isg kämpft nun
ohne die usa fürchten sie eine lang
geplante offensive der türkei in
washington versucht präsident trump
währenddessen seine entscheidung zum
rückzug kleinzureden
wir haben nur so 50 leute in der gegend
aber ich will nicht dass diese 50
verletzt oder getötet werden
keineswegs habe er der türkei grünes
licht gegeben für einen einmarsch in
nordsyrien wenn sie irgend etwas
unmenschliches machen dann werden sie
meinen zorn spüren ich würde ihre
wirtschaft vernichten
er rudert zurück angesichts scharfer
kritik auch aus den eigenen reihen seine
kritiker sprechen von verrat an den
verbündeten kurden und sie fragen was
ist das wort amerikas noch wert der
republikanische mehrheitsführer im senat
schreibt amerikanische interessen werden
am besten geschützt durch amerikanische
führung nicht durch rückzug oder abzug
senator graham eigentlich enger
gefolgsmann von fand legt überraschend
deutlich nach
die kurden standen an unserer seite als
niemand anderes denise bekämpfen wollte
lassen wir sie im stich dann viel glück
bei der suche nach neuen partnern
widersprüchliche signale aus washington
derweil treibt die türkei ihre
vorbereitungen zu einer militäroffensive
voran
sie fährt schweres geschütz im
grenzgebiet zu syrien auf wieder kämpft
brasilien gegen eine umweltkatastrophe
die nordostküste leidet unter einer
schweren ölpest und keiner weiß woher
das öl kommt seit anfang september sind
dort über 100 tonnen aufgelaufen das
berichtet das brasilianische
umweltministerium mehr als 130 strände
sollen verseucht sein
viele tiere sind bereits verändert
zurück nach deutschland
der neue ig metall vorsitzende ist der
alte jörg hofmann bleibt für weitere
vier jahre an der spitze der größten
deutschen gewerkschaft
knapp 2,3 millionen mitglieder hat die
ig metall deutlich mehr als alle
politischen parteien zusammen
die metaller erleben gerade in ihren
schlüsselindustrien automobil und
maschinenbau tiefgreifender umwälzungen
patricia schäfer berichtet es ist eine
art digitale choreografie beim
maschinenbauer ake in passau werden
komplette produktionsprozesse am
computer simuliert bevor die maschine
tatsächlich zum einsatz kommt das ist
was man industrie 4.0 nennt der
technologiewandel der unsere arbeitswelt
radikal verändern wird
das was gestern präsent war und gut war
ist heute vergangenheit so muss man es
tatsächlich sind und das ist die
herausforderung die mitarbeiter ständig
um top von den fähigkeiten zu halten
das geht natürlich über
fortbildungsprogramme so ist ein dreher
oder fräser inzwischen auch software
spezialist er steuert die maschine mit
ständig neuen programmen laufende
weiterbildung der mitarbeiter damit
arbeitsplätze in der neuen welt erhalten
bleiben das ist auch eine forderung der
ig metall
beim gewerkschaftstag in nürnberg sind
viele metaller besorgt mehr als die
hälfte der betriebe rechnen laut
gewerkschaft mit einem arbeitsplatzabbau
durch den technologiewandel für den
63-jährigen ig-metall-chef und erfahrene
tarifverhandlung jakov man eine große
herausforderung dass auch kurzarbeit
schnell möglich ist und mit
qualifizierung verbunden wird
dass wir die möglichkeiten erweitern wie
kann man kolleginnen und kollegen
befähigen auch neue berufsbilder sich zu
anzueignen
der ig-metall-vorsitzende wurde heute
mit nur 71 prozent der
delegiertenstimmen wiedergewählt ein
schwaches ergebnis und auch ausdruck der
zukunft sorgen der deutschen metall- ein
instrument lernen oder im verein fußball
spielen das soll auch kindern aus
ärmeren familien möglich sein deshalb
zahlt der staat zuschüsse über das
sogenannte bildungs und teilhabepaket
doch das kommt nach einer studie des
paritätischen wohlfahrtsverbands bei gut
85 prozent der berechtigten gar nicht an
es sei zu kompliziert und bürokratisch
die leistungen zu beantragen
die schlechte ausstattung der bundeswehr
dazu gibt es jetzt ein neues kapitel
aufgedeckt von den kollegen von
frontal21 es geht um den puma den
modernsten schützenpanzer der welt made
in germany 350 sind bestellt 280 schon
ausgeliefert ein milliarden-projekt doch
es droht zum rohrkrepierer zu werden
denn die ersatzteile wurden zu spät
bestellt bei pannen fangen die soldaten
am zu basteln
monika heise der schützenpanzer puma er
soll der modernste und leistungsfähigste
panzer der welt sein sobald er in den
einsatz kann
doch das großprojekt ist geprägt von
immer neuen problemen
diesmal bleibt der panzer nach
zehnminütiger fahrt einfach stehen dann
hilft nur noch sicherung ziehen
[Musik]
das bundesverteidigungsministerium kennt
die menge hat sie in seinem mehrseitigen
internen rüstungsbericht aufgelistet
größtes problem die ersatzteilversorgung
ein insider aus der bundeswehr berichtet
dass deshalb panzer ausgeschlachtet
werden um einige wieder zum laufen zu
bringen
also wenn man feststellt dass ein panzer
kaputtes wird erstmal geprüft welches
teil das ist und dann muss erst mal ein
panzer gefunden werden bei dem das teil
nicht kaputt ist
das ist nicht so leicht denn bei den
meisten panzern ist ja das gleiche
kaputt auf anfrage räumt das
bundesverteidigungsministerium die
probleme ein und spricht wörtlich von
einer qualifizierten baugruppen
gewinnung fehlende ersatzteile ein
hausgemachtes problem viel zu spät gab
die bundesregierung ersatzteil pakete in
auftrag
ich gehe davon aus dass beim puma in der
ursprünglichen planung einfach diese
dinge aus den verträgen und den
planungen herausgestrichen worden sind
damit die summe nicht so groß aussieht
auf sechs milliarden euro sind die
kosten des panzers inzwischen gestiegen
damit werden die 350 panzer doppelt so
teuer wie ursprünglich geplant
bedingt einsatzbereit mehr zu den pannen
beim panzer puma heute bei frontal21
hier im zdf um 21 uhr
sie haben eine revolution der astronomie
gestartet mit diesen worten würdigt das
komitee die diesjährigen gewinner des
physik nobelpreises
die auszeichnungen teilen sich der
kanadisch amerikanische kosmologe james
peebles und die schweizer
wissenschaftler michelle mayor und
didier queloz
die schweizer entdeckten vor über 20
jahren als erste einen sogenannten
exoplaneten er umkreist wie unsere erde
eine sonne braucht dafür aber nur vier
tage
die forschung der beiden habe die
vorstellung der welt für immer verändert
weil irgendwer beim sport mit ganz ganz
viel fußball dich morgen das testspiel
der deutschen nationalmannschaft gegen
argentinien
bundestrainer löw muss inzwischen auf 13
spieler verzichten im tor diesmal trotz
eines um verletzten kapitäns neuer sein
konkurrent ter stegen das tor derzeit
die einzige position auf der luft keine
personalprobleme hat sogar stürmer sabri
findet gefallen am posten zwischen den
pfosten
doch wie verläuft festgelegt wird marc
andré ter stegen eine chance erhalten
der herausforderer von mandl neuer
betont er verspüre keinen besonderen
druck im ersten spiel nach dem heiß
diskutierten torwart oft wenn man weiß
dass das ich über mich gesprochen hat
das habe ich gesagt damit ist das thema
auch beendet
für uns gibt es keine keine keinen keine
diskussionen keinen streit löw setzt bei
seinen personellen notplan mit niklas
stark in der abwehr und mit luca
waldschmidt dem angriff auf zwei
debütanten bastian schweinsteiger
beendet seine karriere als aktiver
fußballer mit bayern münchen gewann der
2013 die champions league im finale
gegen den bvb und ein jahr später wird
mit der nationalmannschaft in brasilien
weltmeister
bundestrainer löw heute zum
schweinsteigers anschluss er war ein
großer spieler er war eine große
persönlichkeit
so kenne ich ihn immer offen immer
ehrlich immer empathisch gegenüber den
fans die fans mögen ihn
für ihn haben wir immer ein platz bei
uns vierte spiel und vierter sieg in der
em qualifikation die deutsche
frauenfußball nationalmannschaft gewann
am nachmittag gegen griechenland mit
fünf zu null
die us turnerinnen haben heute bei der
wm in stuttgart ihren titel erfolgreich
verteidigt angeführt von der mehrkampf
olympiasiegerin simon beils gewann das
team aus den usa vor russland und
italien
für rekord weltmeisterin bei 2 ist
bereits der fünfzehnte wm titel
[Applaus]
wow ist nur einen meter 42 ist agenturen
die größten ja und ich glaube alle alle
turnerinnen ziehen wirklich ganz tief
den hut vor dieser dann doch großen frau
alles zum wetter da gibt es an den alten
dauer regen sonst bleibt es wechselhaft
waren sich das ändert gleich mit christa
stirb claus kleber begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute journal
wir danken für ihre aufmerksamkeit
wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen abend
unseren morgen wieder da wirklich auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
wer einen schönen abend jetzt am
kommenden wochenende klopft ein bisschen
der goldener oktober an die temperaturen
steigen der beispiel temperatur trend
hier von köln zeigt uns dort morgen
höchstwerte von nur so 13 grad am
samstag und am sonntag sind das dann
aber schon über 20 grad oder heute nacht
gleichen sich die temperaturen bei 7 bis
12 grad etwas an aber bis wir zum
wochenende kommen ist doch normal teils
ordentlich regen mit dabei wie heute
nacht im süden des landes dafür lockert
es über der mitte auf aber die schau an
der küste mit anfangs einzelnen
gewittern bleiben und diese dreiteilung
gibt es auch morgen vormittag also
schauer an der küste in der mitte ist es
meist trocken richtung osten sogar
richtig freundlich und dann gibt's
diesen dauerregen der sich südlich der
donau an den alpen staut und 30 bis 50
mm regen abladen kann
nachmittags kommen dann von westen her
mehr und mehr schauer und einzelne
gewitter
und mit diesem vor allem auf den bergen
und an den küsten bögen südwestlichen
wind schiebt es sich auch im osten zu
mit der sonne hier vormittags gibt aber
16 17 sonst meist 11 bis 15 grad
11 bis 16 grad sind das am donnerstag
bei windiges schauerwetter erst ab
freitag setzt sich aus süden sonne und
wärme durch wobei es im norden erst mal
noch etwas trüber und regnerischer
bleibt